You said this was what, again?
Okay, just give me a second to
positive for
ketamine hydrochloride,
which is a DEA controlled substance.
It's illegal to transport into the U.S.
It's illegal to have in the U.S.
without a prescription.
I honestly didn’t know that was in the bags
he had some medications in here
Is everything prescribed here?
And this one
found another baggie
of brown salt like substance.
So we're going to have to do our checks
and just determine what the substances
Alright sir. Come right in here.
Just put your bags upon the table.
We're going to
check your body, make sure you don't have
anything on talking to Pat down.
We're going to recheck your bags,
make sure we didn't miss anything.
And then we're going to process this thing
where we're going to go from there right
in patting the individual down, we located
a small baggie of a white powdery
substance inside his right pocket,
took it out, asked him what it was.
He immediately said, Oh,
I didn't know it was there.
So now we're going to go
and retest everything
and just to verify what we found
First one
ketamine hydrochloride
again, ketamine always turns up blue.
When we tested
cocaine hydrochloride
the third one's MDMA,
the white powder turned out
to be cocaine hydrochloride.
The ten color salt
like substance turned out to be MDMA
and the pink powder is positive
for ketamine hydrochloride.
We're just going to
put you right back in here.
What is going to
happen is we're going to charge you
a penalty.
The penalty is $5,000.
We can mitigate it down to $500.
This is the one break you're getting.
If you want to call us, you pay the $500.
You get some paperwork
and you'll be on your way right
The passenger was charged a fine.
He was allowed to be released.
Upon paying the fine.
Some things that led into that were his,
you know, his cooperation and with us,
the amount of substances he had on him
just in the future.
Make sure you know what you're
bringing in your pockets, in your bags.
All right.
that does happen.
Often passengers say,
oh, I don't know what was inside this bag,
but part of our inspection is
we ask those questions.
Is this your bag?
Everything inside belongs to you.
So before we even open it up,
you're taking responsibility
for anything that we find inside.